[Musique]
je m'appelle Jacques Mimoun et je pars à
l'assaut des défis les plus extrêmes ou
à voir les bons gestes de survie et une
question de vie ou de mort vous regardez
Jack Mimoun le survivant de l'enfer
couper les gars coupé et puis on son
caïman il y a de la morphine dans le cul
réveille le bal des incapable dedans
monsieur j'adore votre émission je suis
une vraie
fans vous êtes sûr qu'on est au bon
endroit vous inquiétez pas on est
attendu bon alors ce qu'on va faire
on va on va procéder à la fois et puis
je vous emmène un hélicoptère
[Musique]
vous êtes un aventurier
il y a 20 ans mon père s'envoler pour
une destination inconnue et depuis la
plus donnée aucun signe de vie
attention
c'est pas lui que je cherche
c'est ce qu'il était venu chercher ici
on a vécu suffisamment de belles choses
plus d'aventures ce serait la
gourmandise
chez vous les mots sortent comme ils
peuvent quoi vous contrôler rien j'ai
l'impression